why did wendy and marty make that tough
decision what did the car crash really
mean what was up with wendy's time in
the mental health hospital here's the
ending of ozark season 4 explained
spoilers ahead
while sam dermody might be gullible we
can all agree that he still deserves a
pleasant send-off throughout the series
the main characters move him wherever
they need him resulting in him working
for ruth at the lazy-o motel a property
she uses to launder money for darlene
and now look at you look you've landed
this great new job worked out better
than i'd hoped sam ultimately escapes
the ozark madness by looking toward a
higher power he's baptized and leaves
town with nathan and the congregation
meaning that he will no longer
unknowingly aid and abet the main
characters in their crimes at least one
character appears to have a happily ever
after at the ending of ozark
in the final hour wendy makes a bold
move by checking herself into a mental
health facility to get her kids back
charlotte and jonah had planned on going
into nathan's custody giving him a
victory albeit short-lived over wendy i
know he's better than mom
jonah what it's not
he is and besides this will be a good
chance to get to know him
credit where credit's due ruth does play
a major role in keeping the four birds
together when she threatens nathan at
gunpoint in his motel room but it's
windy who makes an emotional gambit to
get the kids back on her side when jonah
and charlotte go visit her she redeems
herself by coming clean about her
brother's death it's my fault
all of it
at long last she takes responsibility
for his demise and apologizes to her
kids which is likely all jonah ever
wanted to hear in the end nathan leaves
the ozarks with the rest of the
congregation while jonah and charlotte
stay by their parents
omar spends most of the final season
behind bars and when he's finally
released from jail he's driven to the
middle of nowhere and killed by an
officer
marty proving to be one step ahead of
everyone for the entire series eerily
foreshadowed omar's death when he told
camila that if omar were to be killed
while transferring it would be
considered fate with omar officially out
of the picture the cartel is turned over
to camila omar was supposed to be
released from prison transferred to
mexico and then broken out to head the
cartel once again but camilla is the one
who gets the final deal with the fbi
resulting in omar becoming a little more
than a pawn in the bird's eventual bid
for freedom
season 4 kicks off with the birds
getting in a major car crash however
this scene isn't revisited until the
series finale although it's common for
fans to try to make every single detail
and decision meaningful this accident
feels more like a misdirect rather than
a major plot development the car
accident however does indicate how much
the family has been through as it
doesn't seem to phase them as much as
fans might expect though they're
initially startled they then hop in a
cab head home and seemingly aren't
affected one bit by the accident however
while it doesn't affect the plot much it
does offer the opportunity for
conflicting viewpoints navarro's priest
looks at the accident as a sign of the
birds lives being destructive how many
times does god have to point at you
before you take notice
wendy on the other hand views the event
as proof that her family is going to be
fine they are alive at the end although
jonah has to murder someone to make it
happen so who knows what comes next for
the birds ultimately it may be up to the
audience to decide which meaning is true
sort of a choose your own adventure of
thematic symbolism
camila may have taken over the cartel
but she still doesn't know who killed
javi for just a little while it looks
like things will stay that way until a
big mood change happens at the gala
camilla pressures claire to give up
javi's real killer it was ruth langmore
camilla then threatens to take out the
bird's children if they attempt to warn
ruth in any way and in the end they
choose their own safety over ruth's life
needless to say the ending of ozark is
bittersweet for the birds and audiences
what if this is too much to bear
it won't be
entering the series finale it appears
that ruth just might get away with
javi's murder right up until claire
gives her up to camilla that is this
leads to camilla waiting at ruth's home
and in a shocking scene killing her with
a pull of a trigger ruth's death leaves
three as the sole survivor of the
langmores
though his storyline is left up in the
air
also unknown is what will happen to
ruth's portion of the casino it wouldn't
be surprising if her stakes in the
company go to three or even rachel
garrison who came back to the ozarks to
help run the casino even if rachel
doesn't get it it was a nice surprise
for fans to see her back for the series
finale
in the final scene melsa team shows up
at marty and wendy's house and reveals
that he finally pieced together ben's
murder however just when it seems like
the birds are finally going to go down
for one of their countless crimes jonah
pulls up with a shotgun the scene ends
with a black screen and a gunshot
fan theories will likely run wild with
this ending but it's pretty evident that
jonah pulls the trigger and the birds
get off scot-free so much for going
legit
for most of the series audiences don't
know if the bird family members will
live or die let alone reunite especially
marty as he is consistently put in
harm's way
yet against all odds the birds make a
deal with camilla and the fbi buying
their freedom from the cartel and
immunity from the fbi wendy continuously
says her family is close to making all
their ambitions a reality though it took
several years and many close calls she
is right in the end when season four
ends the family is free to do whatever
they want with the rest of their lives
no longer taking orders from people who
could have them killed with the snap of
a finger
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one